finding scorpions in the desert at night
is surprisingly easy all you need is an
ultraviolet torch because scorpions are
incredibly fluorescent fluorescence
means their bodies absorb ultraviolet
light and re-radiate it in the visible
part of the spectrum they glow this
bright neon green color but scorpions
aren't the only animals that fluoresce
jellyfish amphibians owls and even
platypuses glow under ultraviolet light
part of this video is sponsored by
capital when shopping more about them at
the end of the show
i'm out here in the desert near
bakersfield california looking for
scorpions with carl clook a professor of
biology at cal state bakersfield he's
been researching scorpion fluorescence
for over a decade if you have a black
light it's really pretty easy if they're
there you're gonna spot them
does he look like he's in a posture to
like
defend himself yeah he's not real happy
okay
grab my high-tech scorpion catching
equipment here it's a tongue depressor
with uh yellow highlighter on it so it
fluoresces the black light so you can
see where it is got it
best technique is usually to put the
vial behind them
that in front of him
that was impressive
all right should we give it a shot
got one
and then just gently focus him back in
and i usually just kind of do a little
slide and crab walk back
there you go and just tilt it up
unbelievable
all right i'm i'm gonna get him but why
are scorpions fluorescent i've got about
12 hypotheses so you test them one at a
time um you have 12 hypotheses about why
the scorpion fluoresces
more like six actually i was being a
little bit almost all scorpion's
fluoresce there i haven't seen it myself
but some that live
the living caves that don't flourish but
it's only like one very small group all
the other scorpions
for us one possibility is just this is a
relic trait it's something they
developed way back when they first came
out on land
and just haven't lost a chemical that
has another function
that just happens to fluoresce there are
plenty of chemicals that fluoresce i
mean we have um internal bodily fluids
at fluoresce and clearly those are never
exposed to uv light so the idea of
having a function for that fluorescence
is kind of silly
this fluoresce is about the same color
as a scorpion but clearly isn't a
scorpion that's actually a rock the
color is a little off but
but that is like what is that
it's plastic from milk bottle
huh
you wanted to know if the scorpions were
fluorescing in order to attract insects
right so how did you test that what i
did was i used scorpions like these ones
and i took half of them and dipped them
in uv blocking marine varnish so they
didn't fluoresce and then i just used um
basically fly paper and took those
things outside and set them side by side
and then found the number of flying
insects that
were caught in each okay so we were
outside in moonlight
and i did the same experiment both under
the new moon and the full moon and so
what i found from that was when there
was a new moon there was no difference
in the number of insects caught by the
fluorescent non-fluorescent scorpions
but under the full moon when there's
nice bright uv light available there was
a difference and the ones that fluoresce
actually caught fewer insects it seems
kind of counterintuitive so that tells
me that my hypothesis was wrong which
happens a lot basically yeah they're not
they're not using their fluorescence to
lure insects in fact the fluorescence is
a bad thing for them in terms of their
ability to catch flying insects at least
but let me ask you this if you find that
fluorescence is counterproductive for
the scorpion in some way doesn't that
indicate that there has to be something
useful exactly there must be something
that counteracts that sort of negative
negative yeah scorpions are really well
adapted for what they do one of the cool
things here is that scorpions
are actually able to metabolize
um iron and nickel
and in their um
pincer here and on the tips of their
claws they actually have basically iron
to strengthen that iron and nickel
at the end of their tail yeah yeah you
can see like the the color here is a
little bit different and it's because of
the iron
that seems very aggressive to me
one of the main things we're interested
in here is how they see so i've seen two
of their eyes so those are the median
eyes right there those two dark spots
yep there's a cluster of three eyes
right there and of course on the other
side so they're symmetrical so they have
a total of eight eyes can they detect
light with parts of their body that are
not eyes
yeah actually they can in a 1968
experiment researchers put scorpions in
half-covered petri dishes then they
exposed them to bright light and all the
scorpions quickly hid under the covered
part of the petri dish
then the researchers painted over the
eyes of the scorpions so they couldn't
see
and repeated the experiment
but when they turned on the light
93 percent of the time the blinded
scorpions still scuttled over to the
covered side
the finding was remarkable
scorpions don't need their eyes to
detect light they can sense it with
their bodies it shows that they have
what's called an extraocular light sense
in their tail so they can detect light
with their tail they can't form images
they can't but they can detect
the tail of a scorpion can detect light
one hypothesis is that they use it to
communicate with one another
the idea being that they use it to
determine primarily whether or not
another scorpion out there is of the
same species for mating
one
fairly low probability hypothesis is
that they can use it as camouflage
because they absorb uv light
if they're sitting on another surface
that absorbs uv light and you have an
organism that sees in the uv like some
owls and things like that can do
they would tend to blend in very nicely
with that
so it's a possibility but not that many
organisms
see in uv and not that many that eat
scorpions see in uv so it doesn't seem
very likely
you go for it
you do it
close
there you go see
one of the ideas is scorpions came out
of the water full
silurian period long time ago and there
was a lot more uv just in sunlight and
things like that then because we didn't
have an ozone layer we didn't have you
know all these things that are blocking
uv in our atmosphere now and so that one
of the ideas is that it actually acts as
a sunscreen it's a way to absorb those
um
damaging ultraviolet photons
and convert them away into something and
basically keep them from penetrating
into the body and causing damage
going home
there you go
we got him and then there have been some
other
ones that are a little bit more out
there um one of which being the one that
i've actually settled on at the end is
that they use it as part of their
sensory system to detect the presence of
flight in the environment so this was a
later experiment after i gave up on the
initial idea
that didn't work
so all i really did in that one very
simple put a scorpion
in each one of these things here
and then put this under ultraviolet
light
and exposed it to ultraviolet light and
so i measured how long they spent
exposed versus unexposed and how many
times they went back and forth
and you were testing scorpions that were
fluorescent and not fluorescent right so
what i did with that was i developed a
technique to remove or at least reduce
the ability of scorpions to fluoresce
simply by exposing them for long periods
of time to ultraviolet light so
basically you're just kind of taking the
chemical that is causing fluorescence in
their exoskeleton and you're photo
bleaching so you're kind of breaking the
chemical not be able to function
properly anymore what we found is the
activity levels um changed significantly
so when you exposed to uv light the
non-fluorescent scorpions acted like
they were in the dark
there was no difference between their
behavior in the dark and in uv light
whereas when uv light was present for
the ones that could fluoresce they
reduce their activity levels
what's the conclusion from that the
conclusion from that is that the
fluorescence itself is acting as a way
to
for them to detect the presence of
ultraviolet light another
researcher by the name of douglas gaffin
came up with a great phrase for it i
wish i'd come up with the phrase but i
got to give credit he calls it a whole
body photon detector so it's part of
their sensory system
what we don't know is why they want to
detect ultraviolet so badly that they
turn their whole body into a photon
detector the suspicion is it has to do
with determining
whether or not they should come out at
night the idea is when uv light hits a
scorpion's body it fluoresces and the
tail detects this emitted green light
alerting the scorpion that it is exposed
so it searches for cover scorpions are
really good at starving for long periods
of time they don't need to eat that
often
and coming out and foraging is dangerous
for them
and so they don't like to come out when
it's a moonlit night typically the only
ones you'll find out in a full moon are
the ones that are really hungry who
really need food if they're well fed
they'll stay down so they're using that
as basically their acuity environment
and saying you know okay this is how
bright it is so that's a cue as to how
likely i'm getting preyed upon and
here's how hungry i am that's the cue
how badly i need to get out and get some
food right and then the trade-off
between those two is basically should i
go out tonight or should i stay in my
hole
if you like overpaying when you shop
well then don't listen to this next part
but if you want to save money then keep
watching because this portion of the
video is sponsored by capital one
shopping a free browser extension that
will automatically find the best deals
when you shop online it's just two
clicks to install and it works on all
major browsers then whenever you shop
it'll work away in the background
comparing prices and testing coupons to
make sure you never overspend on an item
again
as much as i want to save money
searching for bargains and coupon codes
is a big hassle and capital one shopping
lets you get the best deals without
having to waste any of your time finding
those deals in the first place they all
apply automatically at checkout they
even have their own shopping page that
gathers products from across different
sites and picks out the cheapest one so
you can shop directly for the best deals
on the internet and you don't need to be
a capital one customer to use it this
extension is free for literally everyone
so you can start saving money right away
i want to thank capital one shopping for
sponsoring this portion of the video and
i want to thank you for watching